We have seen the last video system equations.
In this video I will show you one of the methods of constraint
Where you do not need
For a graph of the two lines
To see where they intersect.
This will give you an exact rhetorical answer.
In the next videos you will see
More ways to do so.
Now look at these equations.
The first x plus 2y equals 9,
The 3x plus 5y equals 20.
If you have the same process as in the previous video, you can
Draw each of the two lines a diagram,
These are the two lines.
They can be drawn either in the form of an oblique cross
Or the shape of a gradient point.
They are in typical form now.
You can draw both lines and find out
Where they will meet and this could be the solution.
But it's hard to get by just looking
To see exactly where they meet.
So find a way to do it.
The way I will follow is the method of substitution.
I will use one of the equations to arrive
For one of the variables then make the substitution here
So here again.
And Awni explained to you what I mean.
Let me get to x using the first equation.
The first equation says x plus 2y equals 9.
I want to get x value
Of the equation.
My x remains equal to 9 minus 2y
This is the first equation.
It has somehow been arranged.
As the equation shows,
So to achieve the equations, x must
Check the constraint here.
So I can put these here instead of x>
You have concluded in the first equation that x
Equal to this.
Well, if x should equal those
Let me put those instead of x
So the second equation will become 3 x
From x, you write: 9 minus 2y.
3 hit 9 minus 2y plus 5y equals 20
This is called the substitution method.
I have been replaced for x only.
The benefit is that I have one equation
I am anonymous and defy and can now create the value of y.
Do it
3 hit 9 equals 27.
3 hit negative 2y equals negative 6y plus 5y equals 20.
Add negative 6y to 5y
Equation 27 minus y equals 20
Defeating 27 of the parties
You have to let me write that of us.
Let us discount 27 parties.
On the left, 27 and 27 cancel each other
And you have a negative y equals 20 minus 27
Equals a negative 7.
Then you can hit either side
In negative 1 you get y equals 7
Here we found the y value of the intersection point
The two lines. y equals 7.
Write it here
y equals 7
Now that you know the value of y, you can find the value x.
x equals 9 minus 2y
Do not do that.
x equals 9 minus 2 multiply y = 2 multiply 7
Or x equals 9 niggs 14, or x is equal to stby 5
If using the replacement method you can
Access the x and y points
Which achieve the equations
The point x is equal to 5, y is equal to 7.
They achieve equations.
You can check it out.
Equation 1: Passive 5 plus 2 hit 7 equals negative 5 plus 14
Already equal to 9.
Equation 2:
3 hit negative 5 equals negative 15, plus 5 hit y:
Plus 5 hit 7
If a negative 15 plus 35 is already equal to 20.
If this achieves the two equations.
If you want a graph of the equations
They will intersect a negative point 5 comma 7
Now use your skills
To solve the following word problem.
Give you that total
Two numbers equals 70
And the difference between them
Equals 11
What are the two numbers?
Let us resolve this rhetorical question
If you know some of the variables.
Let us assume that X is the largest and that y is
Is the smallest number.
This is just an arbitrary assumption,
One is bigger than the other
The difference between them 11
Now the first assumption is that the two numbers are equal to 70
Means that x plus y must equal
The second assumption is that the difference between them is 11
I mean the larger the minus the smaller
Must be 11
This means that x minus y must equal 11.
That's all you've assumed.
You have two equations and are unknown.
You have a system of two equations
You can solve it using the replacement method.
Let us reach x in this equation.
When you add y
For both ends of the equation, what will be the result?
At the left end, x is left alone
Because these two will negate each other.
In the right hand side you will get an x ​​equal to 11
Plus y or y plus 11.
If x equals 11 plus y
Using the second equation.
You can replace x in the first equation.
Instead of writing x plus y equals 70, you can
Replace x with this
Which we found in the first equation in purple
Now we adhere to it as a constriction of x in the OT equation
So if you put this alternative you get y redundant 11_
In place x _
Plus y equals 70
This is x.
This limitation is taken from this second equation
Or from the second assumption.
I put y plus 11 instead of x
Because this was the limitation
The second equation gave me that.
If you get the value of y.
You got y plus 11, plus y equals 70.
It is the same as 2y plus 11 equals 70.
Then if you put 11 of the parties you get 2y
What will you equal?
59.
Then subtract 10 from 70, get 60
Is 59.
If 2y equals 59
Which can be written: 59 on 2
Equals 29.5
y equals 29.5
Now what is the value of x?
Well, you've come to that x equals y plus 11.
If x is equal to 29.5 _ this is the value of y that we have just recommended _
Plus 11.
Add 10 to get 39.5.
Then add 1 you get 40.5.
Now you have concluded.
If you want to find the intersection of these two lines
Will intersect at the points 40.5 comma 29.5.
You can use this equation to get to x
Then you put this as a substitute.
Duplicate ?????
Duplicate ?????????????????????
???
????
The important thing is to use the restrictions
Now verify the credibility of what you have reached,
What is the sum of these two numbers?
40.5 plus 29.5 equals 70 already.
The difference between them is 11
Their charges are kept away from B-11
I hope you have benefited from this lesson.